mein name ist luca meine lieben freunde
ich darf euch heute mal wieder recht
herzlich willkommen heißen hier am
dienstag zu einer neuen episode wird
sagen wir fangen wir wieder an mit dem
besten tecdoc der woche alter kraft
hinter hier freue mich auf die zeit
gefunden
richtig realitätsnah richtig lesen jahre
immer benutzen aber filter habe ich auch
hier gerade drauf
ist auch kein filter ich habe eine
flasche auf den kopf und sehe aus wie
ein flaschen automat
[Musik]
und an der stelle hab ich dann auch
schon wieder absolut keinen bock mehr
bilden
[Musik]
warum
warum also ich finde das cool aus naja
aber es ist wahr ich naja aber
vielleicht braucht jemand einfach ein
weißes t-shirt 15 euro ist es dann auch
nicht so teuer
ich hab eine bessere idee jetzt
verkaufen wir das für 25 euro ist die
wahrheit nein ich bin deutlich war noch
nicht alles
nein die wohnung die sie so meine lieben
[Musik]
warum
warum bekomme ich sowas empfohlen
[Musik]
ich packe ich meine ich mag tipptopp
selber irgendwie mag ich es auch nicht
[Musik]
es war einfach wie einst im charakter
eine real life ich zeig euch heute wie
eure freunde richtig richtig gut war und
alles was ihr braucht sind zwei handys
und immer beide auf anonym schallt dann
wählte zwei beliebige freunde aus ruft
sie an und macht beide handy auf
lautsprecher in ähnlichen frank hatten
wir schon in der letzten episode tik tok
user hatte die person ist habe ich mit
einem handy gemacht und hat dann eben
wieder konferenz gemacht aber da warum
kremiert mein wecker um 18 uhr ich
endlich schaffen kaffee nicht meine
freude für mich auch dann gibt s nicht
eingeladen hat und wie geht es dir hast
du viel zu tun oder geht ich muss aber
sagen warum machst du denn immer noch
bei mir die arbeit spaß macht das werdet
doch bestimmt öfter mal rauszugehen
konzert oder so verfährt du bist eine
kleine party
[Musik]
so schlecht aber auch wieder so gut
gemacht also angie hast du bock mit mir
auch mal einen kaffee trinken zu gehen
also ich bin dabei liebelt amazon hat
mir bei euch letzten schluck deckel
bestellt wir haben es einfach aus dem
grund liegen neuen braucht unbedingt den
klodeckel stehtisch und ex am geruch
kenne klodeckel also was ich damit sagen
will ist egal wie oft ihr mir klodeckel
werbung schickt ja also trägt jetzt
nicht und freude verfallen und mir
denken war geil
noch so ein cooler klodeckel den gelegt
nur noch oh mein gott ich fühle jede
einzelne aussage dieser frau so sehr
weil ich habe mir letztens einen grünen
belag entferner bestellt mit fünf liter
packung für mein motor terrasse und was
kriege ich jetzt überall angezeigt wer
nicht jeden tag ein sturm peitschte mit
offene meer
wenn ich das gewesen wäre dann welche
werden fordern dann schon tot
[Musik]
anfangen und nie oder hey ich bin nicht
aus okay das ist die wahrheit das ist
die wahrheit genau das gleiche hatte ich
gestern mit einer fliege in meinem
zimmer ich schwöre euch die kommt durch
so einen kleinen spalt im fenster rein
aber wenn ich wieder raus will
fick die erste gegen meine boxershorts
dann die gegen meine fresse zehnmal dann
gegen meine bank
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nein
wie komme ich andauernd auf diese videos
[Musik]
franken
bekommen noch geld
[Musik]
es ist halt auch wieder amerika in so
einer macht also alle anderen machen
einfach mit ja wird schon richtig sein
und da green screen
[Musik]
wow
mein lieber kollege deine mutter hat
mich ganz schön hawks genommen
[Musik]
natur ging
oder wie sport so flach aber irgendwie
habe ich glaube dass ich jetzt mit
meinen 50 kilo
[Musik]
die filme genau drauf
ok wisst ihr was ich aber viel komischer
das video findet er füllt jetzt einfach
in die hände ab und trinken
machen wir
haben
chemielehrer wieder 100 prozent die
wahrheit ich weiß nicht wie es bei euch
im chemieunterricht war beziehungsweise
ist falls sie noch zur schule gehen aber
wenn ihr was immer so auch wenn man
einfach nur ein blatt papier
durchschneiden sollte schutzbrille auf
württemberg geben tipps
[Musik]
ich weiß echt nicht mehr wohin mit
meinem leben machen einfach mal machen
einfach mal weiter nichts mehr zu sagen
oh mein gott hat mich also genervt
zusammengefasst man kann man mittels
nicht reservieren
ok
kommen wir jetzt allerdings auch schon
letzten sektor für die heutige episode
trägt user meine lieben freunde und zwar
hat eine tochter ihre mutter dabei
gefilmt wie sie mit calls umgeht bei
denen sie gescannt wird also mit
irgendwelchen komischen telefonumfrage
menschen die was verkaufen wollen schaut
einfach selbst
die behänge
ja
so gehe ich in mainz telefon wenn sandra
mich anruft kleiner sohn an der stelle
welche heutige politik des seit seinem
sauber enden meine lieben freunde wenn
es euch gefallen hat das gerne einen
daumen hoch unter dem video her da und
schreibt ihr bei euren tik tok namen
unten in die kommentare
falls ihr bock habt in die nächste
episode tik tok you stayed reinzukommen
allerdings befinden wir uns jetzt hier
auch schon im auto meine lieben freunde
wenn ich hier oben auf den 2 darauf
könnte man den kanal kostenlos abonniert
und verpasst keine videos mehr
und hier unten ist video verlinkt das
soeben auf meinem 2 kanal online
gegangen ist nämlich eine reaktion auf
youtube die ihre fans belogen super
video